[Music]
hey guys what's up and welcome to
another episode of congratulations
[Music]
that's it we restocked the new life rips
we restocked the new life rips colorways
we got them all we got the blue we got
the
uh
green we got the
orange i don't even know dude but that
doesn't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter dude a lot of you guys got all
four colorways a lot of you guys are
like when you're gonna restock the pink
[ __ ] pink was one of them and a lot of
you guys are like when you're gonna
restock this and we restocked it and the
blue is the new one and the blue is
going crazy dude if you want to support
the show it's crystallia.com to get some
merch and that's what's up um you know
uh we appreciate you listening we
appreciate you listening on patreon
patreon.comcrystalia you get an extra
episode a month and some other stuff uh
behind the scenes on the with chris
videos and then also you get or uh you
get other stuff too but if you want uh
if you're not on patreon and you're just
watching on youtube uh we
appreciate we appreciate it we
appreciate you there too so um yeah man
[ __ ] [ __ ] got a little bit out of hand
today guess what i had to do i had to
get starbucks starbucks sucks dick
doesn't it it sucks so bad doesn't it it
tastes like the back of a cow's mouth
had to go in and had to scoop it up real
quick dude because your buddy was short
on time because your boy's been busy
lately but it's all good dude but he's
been busy lately and he posted an
instagram picture and people said he
looked happy and he is dude some days
he's not happy and some days he is happy
and you got to roll with them days that
are happy dude because life rips man
and that's fine man some days are going
to be good and some days are going to be
bad wow i'm literally speaking like i'm
gonna kill myself tomorrow but it's okay
i'm not do it everything's great we
shouldn't make fun of suicide but um
yeah dude um the new life rips colorways
and oh man i [ __ ] got on cameo and
whoopsie daisy i didn't mean to get it
all backed up but your boy has to do
some right now he's like [ __ ] a lot
deep in there and he's got to start he's
got a really really after maybe after
this podcast if i'm not tired of talking
i gotta really got to get in there and
start doing these cameos and getting
them done because i got a lot of them
backlogged and it's going to take a long
time but whatever dude collecting racks
you got to collect racks dude you got to
collect racks
so we appreciate you guys dude
um
and that's what's that and that's really
you know i don't know i've been doing
this fight companion thing i like it i
did a bunch of episodes of king and the
sting it was really nice uh i got a we
got a special one coming out uh thursday
king of the sting you guys are gonna be
loving that one dude uh mum's the word
but you're gonna be loving that one and
uh yeah dude it's uh i got a new car and
i'm not gonna tell you what it is you'll
have to see on the with chris video [ __ ]
i may put it up there but uh i'll give
you a hint dude it's got bloody
guts i'll give you a hint though dude is
my is it that time of the month for my
car because it's on its period if you
know what i mean
oh dude he's going to be killing him
with the windows down
it's just going to be insane man
it's got oh it's got bloody guts dude
that's fine open the window let me see
we're bleeding in here
tabasco what is it
but uh so that's that's it man
um
uh and uh
[ __ ] yeah dude but i'm feeling good
today man you know i saw a picture i saw
two pictures of myself i saw one picture
of myself i looked very happy and very
nice i saw another picture of myself and
i looked i looked gray it looked a
little bit translucent i don't know what
color i am i need a tan dude i really
need a tan
and i feel good though i've been eating
healthy you know except for the
nashville hot chicken sandwiches at the
improv
bro i go to the improv when i do the
improv when i do the hollywood improv i
go in there and they're i'm like i
already i'm on my meals dude like i eat
tuna for lunch and then i have a little
bit of a snack and it might be like a
chicken dish with some nice brussels
sprouts or something i get it from chef
mike
right he delivers the food he cooks it
up nice
chef mike he's on instagram and uh and
it's a beautiful thing man i mean those
[ __ ] sometimes i throw it in a
pan i just i mean it's nice in a
microwave but if you really put
something in the pan forget it all of a
sudden you're going gordon ramsay all of
a sudden you're emerald with the boom or
bam what'd he say bam dude you put [ __ ]
in the microwave it's okay right
sometimes you feel like you could taste
the microwave you put it in a pan forget
it dude it's like you should you just
shot that chicken
so i put it i'll go crazy i'll put it in
a pan man i'll put some olive oil on the
pan and then i'll just toss some chicken
on there or whatever
if it's some beef [ __ ] bites i'll put
some beef on there whatever it is dude
he packages it up nicely and then i just
keep it like that and then i eat it and
then i go to the [ __ ] improv and
they're like what would you like and i
and i walk into the improv thinking i've
been healthy let's keep it healthy let's
maybe drink some water some carbonated
water you know how i do it right with
the lacroix at home but they don't have
it they don't have little crayout in a
lot of places they don't have it at the
improv
i could say i want to do my writer but
i'm not a [ __ ] sucker like that you know
i'm not a [ __ ] i'm not a diva
i'm just humble chris right so i go in
and i [ __ ] and i'm a humble chris
driving to the club with some bloody
guts right
so i'm going to the [ __ ] place i mean
i'm humble christmas cars it's that time
of the month for my car but i'm humble
chris when i walk in you know
and i could say i want lacroix stacked
to the gills but i don't
i just get the bubbling water okay so i
walk in i get the bubble of water i want
to be healthy and i walk in i say let's
be healthy get a salad and they ask me
what i want immediately and i look at
them in their eyes
and i say without hesitation
nashville hot chicken sandwich
it's like i didn't have the pep talk
i gave up
when it comes to nashville hot chicken
sandwiches i give up and here's the
[ __ ] real kicker dude i'm not even a
fan of fried chicken
what
i'm not even a fan of fried chicken what
dude then what the [ __ ] why did you get
it
oh it's because i'm a fan of what's
spicy and those [ __ ] go bonkers fire
when you eat them
i mean my whole place
the whole [ __ ] inside of my mouth
dude
i mean it's just speaking of emerald bam
in my mouth bro you got to keep eating
it's that kind of spicy we got to keep
eating because if you don't [ __ ] keep
eating and you take a break all of a
sudden
you're you're like you're gonna die
because it's so hot but if you keep
eating your good because your mouth is
moving right
it's a lot like life just keep moving
dude [ __ ] get spicy but keep chewing
[ __ ] gets spicy
but we keep chewing
and wine fire's laughing because i'm not
making much sense but i am in my own way
right we're all hooked into this matrix
dude this is the log cabin cornered okay
you get it
people be talking about the metaverse
the metaverse is already man we're the
met of the metaverse dude we've been in
here
you feel that grass right i mean it's
not real but you feel it
you feel that tall grass don't you
run your palms on it does that tickle
well we just walk out of a lock cabin
because it sure is nice outside
what are you wearing white sit down
let's share ideas this is a cult okay
so this metaphor is like oh yeah metal
versus hot right now bro we've been in
this metaverse man we're sitting in this
log cabin
i'm not with you physically but i'm with
you and you're with me and that's how we
get through life you've been through
dark times i've been through dark times
we've been through dark times while we
listen to this podcast i took a break i
came back better than ever dude
we're good we got each other we're
listening
okay and we listen to each other most of
you just listen to me but you know how
it is
so i got to the improv the other day i
was doing a show there i don't remember
what it was but uh it might have been
brendan shaw been friends or i can't
really remember but i got there and i
did the show and when i got there i got
off stage and some lady came up to me
afterwards and she said hi
and i was like oh this is a french film
right because you look kind of like you
know you know why i thought you know why
i knew she was french before she even
started talking is because she was uh
one of those kinds of [ __ ] people
that you think is ugly and then in like
three seconds you're like oh no they're
not ugly this is actually one of the
most attractive people i've ever seen in
my life
you know what i'm talking about french
people will really kill you with that
[ __ ] a french woman at that will come up
to you and she'll be like hi and you'll
be like i don't know i don't have the
time because i was just and then you
look at her and you'll and you'll
immediately just like the you'll focus
in on it and you'll be like oh the nose
threw me off but you're a ten
oh those teeth look crowded as [ __ ] but
in a way it works for you
oh too much gel in your hair and i like
the natural [ __ ] but baby isn't that
just your style
right
you make me want to be a citizen of the
blue white and red or whatever their
flag is i have no idea because i'm a
dumb [ __ ]
but still she came up to me and she was
like hi
she was so french that when she was
talking it already felt like she was
touching my face
and i said yeah hi i thought you was
ugly quickly realized one of the most
attractive human beings in my life
okay
all good and by the way i didn't say
sexy i didn't say good looking there's a
there's a huge difference between good
looking sexy hot and they're just plain
old attractive
right
do you know what i'm talking about
with those striking features because if
you're attractive you can get away with
having a [ __ ] bonkers ugly nose
or a weird mouth or maybe your lips
don't match your face i'm secretly
talking about me
but you can get away with being
attractive right because there's like
this aura about you
this french charm
i don't remember what she was wearing
but it was all one piece of fabric right
it wasn't pants in a shirt it could have
been a sundress it could have been a
jumpsuit it was all one piece of fabric
i have no idea
and she was just like hi
and i said oh hi how you doing and she
said i'm a big fan do you mind if i take
a picture with you and i said sure why
not
and we took a picture and she said i
just want to tell you um when you were
gone for a long time it was amazing it
is amazing you came back i really we
miss you you know you have fans out
there and i said oh thank you very much
and she and then i went to go take a
picture with someone else and then she
popped by like it was the sequel right
like we shot a whole french film it was
over
and then she popped by and wanted to say
something else like it was a sequel
and she said can i also say something
else for you
and i said well sure she was nice enough
and i and she said i just want to say
that everybody has their problems and it
is okay and we don't judge you for that
and we don't care we are your fans
but you look skinny
i said huh
she said i want to make sure you're
healthy because you look skinny
and i said oh no i'm i'm good i'm a
beefcake
cake you know it's crazy like my
shoulders go on for days and nights but
she broke me dude you know like i was
wanted to go into that mode like no it's
fine look sweetheart they they shoot the
lord of the rings on my back i mean
hollywood's on location right here and
she says
you're skinny and i was like
and it kind of broke me a little bit you
know it was like a real moment she was
like i hope you're healthy and you're
eating okay but you look skinny
and i was like well thanks for caring
you know
and then i walked out and i told my
friend what the [ __ ] happened and he was
like
my friend is so [ __ ] he's like so
boring he was just like well you know
what it is is a lot of the time you know
it's a real like middle uh it's it's
european it's a very european thing to
and i was like yeah i brought i didn't
want to do this whole thing okay
just it's some chick called me skinny
and it's fine dude i got lost in a
french moment that's it i got lost in a
french [ __ ] i had a french connection
and this [ __ ] chick told me that i
was skinny and now i got now i got to
worry about doing some [ __ ] dips and
chin ups man
i mean i'm like sorry strong guys of
course i'm like to the limit with my
[ __ ] striations but this chick just
broke me immediately by having a moment
man
that's that french connection man only
french people could really break you
like that honestly
so i'm skinny and it's fine but it's all
good and it's fine
right
but we've been having some good shows
i've been going up a lot lately man i've
been really going up a lot i've got
dates in brea i've got dates in irvine
and brea california you can go to
crystallia.com
scoop them up they might be sold out
already but i don't know i'm not sure
when this podcast is gonna come out yet
uh but yeah the dates are coming and uh
it's gonna be on and popping dude chris
and friends i'm bringing some friends
with me um and i'm doing a lot of local
dates now because i don't want to get
out there on the road but i'll get out
there on the road at some point uh when
i get out there on the road i'll
probably just be doing my own show not
to almost throw up in my mouth not the
crystalia and friends
uh
so yeah we'll see maybe we'll book some
theaters or whatever i thought maybe
i'll just kick around and do some clubs
but i don't know man maybe i'll just
come out full force and just [ __ ] fo
let's go mach 11 on the [ __ ] tampa
theater or some [ __ ] who knows dude
maybe we'll go mach 11 on the [ __ ] uh
i don't know
but what i do know is [ __ ] one fire
is absolutely [ __ ] up baby whoa dude
he's [ __ ] up so bad dude he's mr
gadget i swear to god he's inspector
it's so annoying dude he comes in and he
goes like this check it out and he holds
up a [ __ ]
dude it's i'm not kidding it's this big
dude it's this big can i [ __ ] show it
dude yeah here come on it doesn't matter
if it breaks right dude
i don't want to how do i swipe up wow
dude this is this [ __ ] thing you know
dude it's so shinty
dude all right i think scrolls doesn't
say
this is an iphone dude it's so [ __ ] man
this is like some [ __ ] that [ __ ] tom
hardy would have just because he's too
small and he wants to look normal size
this is so ridiculous it's a [ __ ] i
it's an iphone that he got where'd you
get it [ __ ] in china it's from china
right
on the website he says he goes it's on
the website a website that is chinese
dude it's an iphone it does everything
that an iphone does and i said how much
is it and he said 19 000 and i was like
you know what it could be and then he
said no it's seventy dollars and i was
like i believe that too and it's a piece
of [ __ ]
and you can use it to call
have you used it to call anybody yet you
could use it to call and then i'm so i'm
[ __ ] doing the podcast and as i'm
doing the podcast he's like it does
everything a regular phone does yeah
except look cool
he's and so i'm doing the podcast and i
see him and he's doing it like this like
so [ __ ] like trying to record me and
then all of a sudden i hear my voice
back to me and he's going and he's going
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] like a [ __ ] all like
like one of those old dudes with an
answering machines
like where he's like we don't know how
to turn it off and that's what you hear
on the answering machine
right before you hear
okay yeah leave a message how do i turn
it off like an old guy
um
wow such a [ __ ] iphone it's two inches
long you know
remember when phones were [ __ ] small
as [ __ ] you just go like this hold on
dude i'm getting a call
hello
and then all of a sudden they were like
now we wanted the flex right we wanted
the flex the flex was the small s
small phone in like 2009 the flex was
the small phone and then the and then
the iphone came out what in like 2008
maybe
2007 knows immediately dorky and uh in
2007 the iphone kind of changed that and
the flex became the big [ __ ] and then
people got big phones and now the phones
are like real big
and i even get rid of was in here and it
was like i think that you know that the
flex is gonna be now the small phones
are bleak i'm gonna be coming back and
it's like yeah dude the smaller the
better dude i mean it's nice to have but
like it's like dude you're getting the
iphone and you're also getting a laptop
or a uh and some people have an iphone
uh uh what do you call them the ipad and
a laptop remember when they tried to
sucker us into an eye touch
dude if you had an eye touch you're a
piece of [ __ ] you know that right
it does everything an iphone does but it
doesn't call
okay it's cheaper but also save up for
the iphone do the i touch remember that
bitch-ass thing it didn't do any dude if
you you if you bought an iphone and you
still feel like you didn't get had your
brain's broken you know that right
and apple apple suckered you into buying
that [ __ ] i touch
they that was some that was some that
was the [ __ ] man
they had so many [ __ ]
wow man me and my brother when we got
ipods when they first came out we slept
we were so excited we had ipods that we
slept and uh we got them for christmas
and then on christmas night we we slept
with them with listening to music dude
probably listening to green day or
whatever the [ __ ] he was listening to
and it was so cute dude and the song
would change and it would [ __ ] light
up the whole room and i'd be like matt
and he's like no yes my ipod
but yeah
man um
so phones need to get smaller remember
those [ __ ] flip phones how dope those
were remember the top heavy ones you'd
open them up and you'd and they'd
[ __ ] the weight would catch you off
guard you'd be like oh [ __ ] and it would
just fall on the ground and then you
[ __ ] with the big ass antenna that
did absolutely [ __ ] nothing by the
way
you don't need antennas in your phone
i was so worried about getting cancer
when cell phones came out and then i
just realized everyone's gonna get
cancer anyway because everyone dies of
cancer always how many people in your
family have gotten cancer
see
um
so that's what's up
g unit that's what's up can't say the n
word part but
word part
g unit that's what's up
um gotta go on this instagram post dude
i'll just do it for my phone
[ __ ]
my this is my favorite crossover
on instagram
where's your um
it's from my group text
my favorite crossover on instagram byu
virgin
is an instagram account it's got 43
000.1k followers
i guess i don't need to say a thousand
if i'm saying okay but
brigham young brigham young
virginity club used utah-based club
dedicated to preserving and promoting
virginity on college campuses no
affiliation with byu
and then it's just like using byu
mormonism
to talk about abstinence and [ __ ]
and the the what they posted for
this is my favorite crossover right here
they posted for
no nut november
hey
you're a mormon school
don't
don't write
no nut november
in your posts
call it something else
call it abstinence november dude here at
byu we want to make sure you're not
nutting
here at
here at byu we want to make sure that
you never get some
that you that you're not trying to
pursue uchiwali
[Laughter]
here at byu we want to make sure you're
focusing on studies and not going for
that fried butterfly or fresh or fresh
hatchet wound
dude call it something
more clinical
you're a college not a [ __ ] street
urchin
no nut november byu club is like on it
we got it dude what are we doing for
dude i imagine them in the [ __ ] like
it's 24 like it's the show 24 with jack
bauer and all the people and they're in
the [ __ ]
the computer uh place whatever the [ __ ]
the office is and they're just like what
do we got for no not november we gotta
post something now
if they start splurting if they start
splurting out a wedlock
oh man i see i see i see a
i i got someone i got a sophomore i got
a sophomore pursuing the uchiwali
get that get that instagram post up it's
no not november so here it is um if
you're this is and it's a fi it's a
slider dude it's one of those instagram
sliders it's a five part slider
well this is it's a six part slider
here's the first one no nut november
tips from a pro ah
a pro of what a pro of not doing
something how are you a pro of not
[ __ ]
you can only be a pro a [ __ ]
uh oh i'm a pro of not baseball
see how i did it
um
no nut november tips from a pro here i
slide it
but by the way this is the caption tag a
friend that could use these tips to make
it through no nut november oh dude no
[ __ ] you're not affiliated with byu
wow how does it have 43 how many of
these followers are ironic by the way
okay here we go
if you're if you're in a relationship
make it here's number one if you're in a
relationship make a pact with your
partner to remain abstinent if you can't
wait until marriage at least wait until
next month
okay a month at a time i understand that
that's some a [ __ ] i love that we get it
number two take a cold shower not only
are cold showers good for your health
but they'll help you cool off when
things are getting hot
okay cool those two are okay a little
sad that you had to post it but they're
okay here's number three establish a
safety plan with your virginity buddy
weird
hey dude hey two dudes hanging out you
guys friends nah this is my virginity
buddy
oh yeah yeah what what is that all about
well you know when we go nuts and we're
trying to [ __ ] get that fresh hatchet
wound or what have you uh right uchiwali
uh well we got each other's backs you
know
because we can't be succumbing to that
fried butterfly can we uh whenever uh
establish a safety plan with your
virginity buddy wow virginity buddies
are is so a movie that would be in
[ __ ] 1992
right with someone that's so famous now
but wasn't
but it wasn't it was back then dude
like don cheadle would be the third lead
in it oh
dude
don cheetah would be 25 in the third
lead in it
and it was about the two other guys
oh dude he calls it real nice dude i
guarantee you if in somewhere in an
alternate universe there is a movie that
came out in 1992 called virginity
buddies and don cheadle is the [ __ ]
third and a young jeremy renner is one
of the other guys yes dude he figured it
out he figured it out and the second guy
is dead he got hiv no doubt dude he died
in 2001 from hiv turned into full blown
aids dude 100 that's a movie
virginity guy virginity buddies starring
jeremy renner a guy who had hiv but died
of full-blown age in 2001 and [ __ ] uh
what's his name captain america dude don
cheadle is the third lead dude and you
didn't know who he was
and it's been on [ __ ] all month on
like hbo max right
and you're like that's not cheating
jeremy renner oh wow he calls it like he
sees it dude he gets real nice with it
man especially when you want to go 90s
so anyway it's established a safety plan
with your virginity buddy whenever you
feel like you're about to sin
text them your safe word wow so they can
come pick you up hey how about text
hey bro
one hey bro i'm horny what do i do safe
word text to safe word
text the safe word
it's
all of a sudden just chilling you're
hanging out on the [ __ ] car you're
hanging out
you're hanging out with your mom and
[ __ ] and your phone goes off
and it says text from
carl
potato
what's that all about oh nothing
potato poot potato potato why does he
keep texting potato
okay so i have to come clean because i
don't lie because i'm mormon um
so i follow this account called byu
virgin and uh we're trying to not have
sex uh and uh
whenever i feel like i'm about to sin or
he feels like he's about to sin carl
supposed to text me uh safe word and
it's potato so
i have to call him right now he might be
deep in somoshiwali
here's number four here's the [ __ ]
fourth slide download an app on your
devices safari to filter out
inappropriate content we recommend porn
block plus and block site to keep you
safe on the world wide web well that's
actually something i didn't know you
could do and probably need it uh five
avoid sticky situations sinuendos gross
come as sticky uh avoid sticky
situations that may test your commitment
for example when becky invites you over
to study and chill
and then in parentheses but it's already
dark outside and her roommate isn't home
you better off you're better off
removing her from your contact list
altogether wow dude
wow
just cold as [ __ ] with this by you
living just cold as [ __ ] just ice cold
yo becky we ain't even friends anymore
what yup
you texting me past nine to quote
unquote chill and study you know what's
gonna happen we'll both be laying
horizontal by [ __ ] 9 30.
screaming [ __ ] spanish this is amazing
dude
wow dude
unreal
wow they do stories let's see what they
put
what's this
oh hi i didn't see you there me my name
is lace honorable you you have now been
invited to have the best sex of your
life
byu virgin the largest community of
virgins and born again versions studies
show 96 percent of people engage in
premarital sex now that's what i call a
stinky situation
abstinence is difficult i myself was
tempted just the other day when a young
lady asked foul likes to be fellated by
her on a tuesday night the byu version
offers support and resources to show you
the benefits of purity contrary to what
our name suggests we're here to actually
help you get laid just in the right way
would you like to have sex with me no
thank you while i'm flattered i'm sure
you're very good at quitters i'm saving
myself for marriage so come get laid
with us and have the best sex of your
life after those church bells ring and
remember just because you're a virgin
doesn't mean you're a loser and that's
power
purity power byu version
this is awesome dude this has to be
taking the piss wow this is awesome
follow
this is [ __ ] hilarious dude
but they're not following any comedians
so is it actually are they taking the
piss
well my brother follows it cool um
some guy commented no nut lifetime
this is [ __ ] hilarious this
i hope it i mean i hope it's real but it
can't be
i don't know maybe dude i mean here's
the deal whether it's real or not you
know people follow it for real so there
that's it that's all you got to do right
it doesn't matter if it's ironic or not
um
yeah
let's check out this [ __ ] dude i was
watching this what's up with the island
boys we haven't checked in with them for
a long time right they're still going
people still [ __ ] are in it and [ __ ]
remember when i i put out on tick tock
how how much how funny it was and and
everyone was agreeing before i put out
how funny it was and then when i put it
out everyone's like stop bullying them
and i'm like oh dude
really you guys are gonna stab me in the
back too now not just my friends
um
fly soldier posted this
here we go
first of all it says
it says only lamborghini he can afford
he's in a little lamborghini like uh
like that calvin my son would drive and
he's driving the [ __ ] um the dude is
uh with the hair with the with the with
the dildos on his hair by the way
there's a jurassic park poster on the
background which is hilarious it's like
take that down [ __ ] you know uh
and so he's responding to someone's
um
post
about
what only lamborghini he can afford
because he's in this little lamborghini
and so he's now
gets up out of this lamborghini this
little lamborghini
i'm meant for this life
wow
and he gets in a mustang
it's a mustang
i mean not a flex you know
damn boy um
[Music]
worst song of all time is a convertible
[ __ ] not no deeper meaning at all
dude
how can you say like yeah i can't afford
oh yeah i can't afford a lamborghini
check out my mustang
ah [ __ ] a fraction of the price
like
they gotta know right
and then i love people comment exactly
no lamborghini it's a mustang
yeah i mean we know you know
how do you do that how do you lack that
much self-awareness
wow
i'm a mustang boy also do you have
another song
or do you just implement the [ __ ]
[ __ ] with the one song i'm a mustang boy
just trying to make it
it's a five point oh red on black it's a
convertible
so bad um
i can't believe that french lady said i
was skinny when i got [ __ ] shoulders
that go on for days put a week on it but
whatever how about the liver king man
what's he doing
hey hey liver king
grow
hey liver king
stop getting so buff dude somebody
commented on the liver king's uh post
this is the if you're not have you
haven't been with us and don't know who
the liver king is he's basically a guy
who absolutely listens to joe rogan and
has so many guns and has a tank he
actually has a tank
and um
he eats bone marrow like legitimately
and fish balls and guts uh raw
it's [ __ ] gross but uh
he says this guy commented on the liver
kings thing please tell me that you at
least shower regularly i'm sure our
ancestors didn't but we have access to
running water now so it's different
because he's always talking about how
he's like ancestors and [ __ ] and he
calls his uh fan base prime primals or
something
he writes i don't per se liver king
doesn't waste time on such matters wow
talking in the third person is something
of course a guy named liver king would
[ __ ] do like he's uh ricky henderson
uh liver king doesn't waste time on such
matters i also don't use deodorant brush
my teeth or wash my hair
ew dude
hey guy
evolve
ew dude
ew imagine how [ __ ] smelly that dick
is
you know what i mean imagine you just be
around him he's like bro come on man are
you [ __ ] kidding me like at a party
uh get out of here
how mad would you be oh your breath bro
your armpits smell [ __ ] it smells
like the
fish you suck the balls out of
[ __ ] out of here you'd be so mad you
know just everyone would be mad ew get
out of here boo boo boo boo
and you'd be like oh with this spear
but i thought i thought it was popular
yeah online we can't smell you you
[ __ ] short [ __ ]
you're too wide go
i don't waste time on such matters dude
i don't use deodorant brush my teeth or
wash my hair our species has an elegant
brilliant design by default i don't
believe it's ancestral nor is it in our
best interest to block
thermoregulatory mechanisms or disrupt
our skin
hair and beard
biomes wow this sentence doesn't end
with modern day consumer products in
parentheses which is why i rinse off
with well water and take a bar of tallow
rendered soap to the groin and pits and
call it a day
not what the phrase call it a day was
intended for
i stopped modern day hygiene habits over
a decade ago oh is that when you stopped
growing bro
i stopped wearing deodorant i've never
cleaned my beard ever i can tell you
that living by the nine ancestral tenets
your detox pathways body odor and
pheromones will improve and you will
smell look and feel the way that nature
intended you to smell hey dude shit's
natural too
rub it under your nose
hey put your money where your mouth is
have a [ __ ] stash
body odor he says our detox
body odor and pheromones will improve
and you will smell look and feel the way
nature intended you to smell look and
feel and it will confer a fitness
advantage for life
dominate your environment
and make
sure you're on the liver train
hey dude you know there's a lot of
natural stuff that smells utterly putrid
a hyena carcass smells bad you're not
wearing it
it's okay to smell good
wow dude now i just put a [ __ ] tallow
bar of soap up my ass and call it a day
and eat bones
everyone's losing their goddamn mind huh
that's just what's up between the island
boys and the liver king
the liver king is an evil villain you
know that right
got the starbucks
sometimes i go on and i get it free the
guy gives it to me free and sometimes i
go and he doesn't dude shout out to
[ __ ]
um abc clothing man they're [ __ ]
killing it
they sent me a bunch of stuff i almost
wore it but it's a hoodie and it's too
hot
um
but yeah they're great
advisory board crystals man they're so
good
i love this i love this [ __ ] their new
[ __ ] bangs dude
they sent me a grip of it and we support
it on there they support us we support
we they support congratulations we
support advisory board crystals man
they're killing it we love that [ __ ] um
yeah man uh you know so if you want to
look like me and also you can get the
chris liam or the life rips merch all
the colorways crystallia.com we're
having a good time hearing
congratulations you know it's it's
interesting i have a show tonight i'm
trying to conserve my energy because
right now i know you're listening to the
podcast when you listen to the podcast
but also
uh i'm shooting this podcast at 5 p.m
and then i have a show right after and
your boy's gonna be [ __ ] firing on
some low syllables i'll tell you that
much but he'll go to the coffee bean
clear this starbucks coffee down the
iced americano
dry
get his second win and blast off into
outer space on the show cause dude's
been blasting off man i'll tell you my
set
this
he's got it now right when he came back
it was a little bit trepidatious but now
what are you gonna say what are you
gonna do
huh your boy comes on stage he's real
open and honest with you but he's also
getting those chuckles out so what are
you gonna say
right your boy dips into a little bit of
a deep ted talk but also he's still
providing them chuckles
okay he'll hit you over the head with a
guffaw
right after telling you some real
personal [ __ ] so what are you gonna say
okay
let's talk about this [ __ ]
nationality challenge i can we can't
play the music but i'll just play it
silent i guess
either that or
so this is a thing on tick-tock
this is how i look in different
nationalities and this is by
a near band
it's always like indian or asian people
that do it it's never like a white guy
or a black guy i guess it'd be hard for
a black guy to do it right
because that the color of his skin is
kind of like
it overcomes all the other colors of the
skin
of other skin
probably get canceled for saying that
but
um
yeah it's this guy who is this is i
don't even know what nationalities guy
is
he looks like he's maybe
anyway
anyway how i would look in different
nationalities
and then he says which suits me the most
nationality challenge this is a [ __ ]
challenge on tick tock kha'zix so he
says so here we go
come on go
so the first one he has is kazakhstan
wait here kazakhstan
oh usa oh he just put black makeup on
china why was in blackface and now he's
uk well how does this guy look so
different in turkey well what do people
in turkey look like anyway i don't even
have a clue korea okay
oh japan in a mess
[Laughter]
nothing's more japanese than wearing a
metz jersey dude you ever think of that
wow man
bro you could go to [ __ ] new york you
could go to queens
new york you could go to massbeth you
could be in the heart of queens
and where that message is you won't get
as much love as you would if you're in
[ __ ] tokyo forget it dude
japan
oh that's it that's all of them mostly
all of a lot of them are korean dude
he's in blackface dude
tick tock is the wokest [ __ ] we gonna
say something
it's a deep fake okay cool it doesn't
matter dude
racist also tick tock is the most woke
[ __ ] of all time
how's this okay
are you woke or not
dude tick tock is so completely woke and
then they're just gonna do some [ __ ]
like nationality challenge dude people
don't give a [ __ ] about anything but
that brings in the dollars that's what i
love about this [ __ ] man everyone's like
yeah with the rogan [ __ ] when neil is it
neil young is that his name is it neil
young
and neil young is like well oh dude this
is what i love it dude spotify first of
all spotify talking like
taking any road to where it's like
free speech is hilarious like they're so
woke spotify's woke as [ __ ] but above
all
besides being woke and liberal is above
all the dollar is what speaks
as long as i can stack my money in a
pyramid that touches the sky
i'll be right left
centrist from mars i don't give a [ __ ]
and that's everybody okay it's everybody
in big business i'll tell you that much
so
so rogan is like the biggest thing on
spotify since [ __ ] spotify's news so
i don't know
but he's the biggest thing on spotify
we know because we got a huge bump in
spotify
when rogan
went over to spotify everyone's like
okay i guess we'll just listen to
spotify now and they do a lot of
listening on podcasts and spotify they
provide rogue provided a bump
okay
fine
so neil young
now he's saying because a lot of people
are saying that rogan is um
spreading misinformation on the vaccine
which
you know rogan thinks what he thinks and
if that's what he thinks then that's
fine i know scientists i don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on with jabs and
vaccines and not vaccines and masks and
not masks i don't really know you know
why i'm alone i'm a lone i'm a lowly
jester
okay
but my but
the mainstream media obviously is lying
cause clicks
mainstream media is obviously lying
rogan's got hundred million dollars he's
not lying
right
he's just saying what he thinks
and then he has other people with
opposing views on sometimes views of his
and sometimes opposing views
and you know he talks to him sometimes
he beats him up sometimes they get the
best of them but they usually have a
grown-up conversation so whatever you
want to think fine i'm not going to
change your [ __ ] mind
but
neil young is saying well rogan's
spreading misinformation
on the vaccines now we know that the
world is in political turmoil especially
america right
so
neil young says spotify
it's either me or rogan if you want to
leave rogan on
you've got to pull neil young's music
now we all knew how it was going to go
first of all i didn't know neil young
has a lot of people listening to his
music i mean he's got a lot of people
listening to his music hey chris name
one
neil young song
can't do it all right
i don't really know music that well
because i [ __ ] don't like music but
neil young have no idea what his [ __ ]
song is like
so
spotify is like hey
uh
see ya
rogan provides a bump so neil young
and now people on the right it's
hilarious because they're like today's a
great day for free speech i have my
buddy text me great day for free speech
and i'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
spotify doesn't care about free [ __ ]
speech
and the slightest
they care about
stacking their money in a pyramid until
it touches the sky
that's all they care about make no
[ __ ] mistake if neil young was that
[ __ ]
that helped them stack racks in a
pyramid until it touched the sky
there'd be no rogan
they don't give a [ __ ]
it's about bags and that's it
all right let's do some misconnections
guys it's time for everyone's favorite
segment miss connections
um here we go
car head
straight for the point huh in marina del
rey that's a beautiful place to get some
car head i'll tell you that it's a beach
it's really breezy you go to marina del
rey it's like 20 degrees cooler than
wherever you are in los angeles it's
[ __ ] quite annoying because you're
going a different outfit and you're like
what the [ __ ] is all this [ __ ] it's so
cold
so the
header is car head
and then he says sup attractive dad type
what is dad type by the way
guy
or just schlub then what's up with the
attractive
something's fishy already and guess when
i realized that when i saw carhead
attractive dad type looking to connect
with a dude's mouth on my cog
so
showed his hand
was starting off
little just you know the trees and the
clouds and the beautiful grass and then
all of a sudden
went to mach 11.
attractive dad type looking to connect
with the dude's mouth on my [ __ ]
car head is great i'll zap you a pic if
you want to see what you'll be working
with
ah
all
how is the most defensive part
using the word zap for send
hey i'll zap it i'll zap you a pic of my
[ __ ]
god here's another one johnny where are
you like that's written by a blind guy
hey johnny
i lost your contact info if you see this
get back to me contemplating setting up
a whole lot of
uh
dl fun
you were a younger straight guy and
athletic playing for the college
baseball team hopefully you see this
post if not him but similar to him
i mean how the [ __ ] do people know
if you're similar to the guy whose name
is johnny that played on a team
hey if you look like a guy on a team hit
me up i love
[ __ ] um
uh if you're not him if not him but
similar to him and interested hit me up
reply with your info age height weight
in first response your pick will speed
things up
zap me a pic no that was me uh okay
mechanic temple city area wow how many
mechanics are in temple city for real
20 of people living in temple city are
mechanics uh here we go need help with a
blown rod
i like how all these [ __ ] are
like need help like assist need
need a [ __ ] [ __ ] drainage assistance
cock's all pent up
need needs some [ __ ] uh need some
work on my [ __ ]
uh here we go mechanic need help with a
blown rod all suggestions welcome
i am mobile if you need help or would
like to help me feel free to email me
anytime
well guy going with the email huh you
know he's older here's another one
what the [ __ ]
saw you in eminem's music video culver
city felt like you could feel me staring
from up top but couldn't take my eyes
off you cute femme looks
this definitely could be for me
i'm in an m m video
this guy is talking to me i'm gonna hit
him up dude and hopefully get my [ __ ]
rod blown
i'm gonna zap him a pic and hopefully i
could connect with a dude's mouth on my
[ __ ]
wow
was this guy a listener of
congratulations did he just crack the
code did he game the system as they used
to as we used to call it here we go be
there at 9 00 a.m
that's the the header uh be there at 9am
let's meet again
at the norms
i love how he put a zero instead of a an
o in norms like it's code
like it's neo writing it where we had
pancakes that night i'll be there around
9 00 a.m on friday would reply with my
nickname dude
9 a.m is like
such a weird time to be
sneaky
would you just drop your kids off to
school
and you want a quick suck in the back of
norms after eating pancakes
um
here's another one you were at gas
station with short dress think it means
white short dress from la puente since
it's from la puente maybe it's english
isn't his first language those legs and
ass got me that's it dude that's it
right to the point ass is spelled a
space s space s space
amazing dude those legs and ask
got me got to go to craigslist dude ah
[ __ ] man driving home you know what dude
i tried to make sure that it didn't but
those legs and ass sure got me can't
wait to get to my laptop
here's a great header white truck me
waving hey bro
long beach
construction friendly guy in the white
truck me saying hi i'd like to see you
this guy's saying hi way too much in
this post
white truck me waving hey bro
construction from the guy in the white
truck me saying hi i'd like to see you
three said hi three times in the post
that
everyone on craigslist is a sexual
deviant all good um
amazing dude
and we got through the episode of
congratulations without even using
the [ __ ] sound board
they said we couldn't do it but we did
it
haters said we had to use the renner's
thing
oh we did it
haters probably didn't even realize that
your boy brought up jeremy renner in the
middle of the podcast and he still
didn't use this thing
your boy's actually real sick with it if
he wants to be i don't [ __ ]
my new car is coming tomorrow apparently
it's that time of the month because it's
red and sign cyanides on its period
it's showing up with tinted windows a
lot of people get their car and they
[ __ ] go get it tinted and showing up
with [ __ ] darkest [ __ ] you won't even
be able to see the bloody
guns it's all good and that engine in it
is nice
you're probably wondering what that car
is like but [ __ ] i'm not wondering
i'll just tell you this much it's a boss
mobile
oh [ __ ] it's got a black top but it's
actually not black what's that mean the
roof is open
it's not open it's not a [ __ ] drop
top the titties aren't out but the whole
thing is glass god damn it
the birds will be able to see the bloody
guts what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] tweet tweet what are those
bloody guts god damn it
it's [ __ ] amazing he didn't he done
dot it again dude
god damn it did he start the car or did
[ __ ] 900 horses just [ __ ] roll up
outside of my street [ __ ] car
for real dude those tires just keep on
spinning i asked the guy does the car
get lower because it looks pretty low
now and he said of course it does it's
in transport mode his car's basically
underground
jesus [ __ ] christ and it looked low
already jesus christ congratulations the
bloody guts go lower come on dude
that the bass goes underground get out
of here man
come on man
[Laughter]
he's got a whole [ __ ]
he's got a whole goddamn [ __ ] it's
like a 90 inch [ __ ] tv screen for the
[ __ ] shit's [ __ ] forgetting man
anyway dude
god damn it dude if you're going to hit
the [ __ ] life rip [ __ ] hit the life
rip [ __ ] report the uh
support the show report the show support
the show like and subscribe man if
you're not making love to that like
button and taking the [ __ ] subscribe
button out to dinner then you ain't
living dude make friends in the comments
now dude report under the comments hey
friends report on the comments make
friends ask people to go to red robin
ask people to go to arby's ask people to
go to [ __ ]
uh what's that one olive garden ask
people to go to marie calendars make
friends in the comments let's get that
algorithm going and always remember dude
life rips
and your boy provides bomb
on guest appearances so go check all
those out hey guys that's the episode
for youtube but check it out there's
much more on patreon patreon.com
crystalia you get to show the rest of it
okay you get the rest of this show and
you get the rest of all the other shows
with no ads no commercials no anything
like that and uh we get on the patreon
we also have one extra show a month it's
all for just six dollars we have behind
the scenes for our vlog that we do the
with chris stuff we've got more footage
of everything uh that we do and uh and
we have a discord that we chat on it's
fun
we get personal
patreon.comcrystalia
go ahead and sign up huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
that is so stupid